[Music]
let me summarize why
my wife my daughter and i are moving out
of los angeles we decided to buy a house
outside of la
for youtube i'm not going to talk about
where it is but
we'll talk about it on the private
podcast but it's in a small community
about 8 000 people right and there are
several reasons why we wanted to move
out of l.a not to flee los angeles
because i really enjoy los angeles los
angeles is the only big city where i'm
like i feel drawn to it
and as an introvert i actually feel like
i've thrived for the last five years in
los angeles but throughout the pandemic
we started looking and we decided it was
time to leave for several reasons one is
we couldn't afford to buy a house in los
angeles between the down payment and i
don't want to do a mortgage it's beyond
15 years but i can pay off in 15 years
and
what we learned is even where our studio
is here there are houses that are tear
down houses that are 2.7 million dollars
and we learned that the average home in
all of la county which we're moving out
of la county but the average home in all
of la county is 700 000 but that
includes places
that are less desirable to live and so
the house that we bought outside of la
county it's in a small town 8 000 people
it feels like a community and we spent
time in the community for over the
course of almost a year learning the
community the local people in fact we
made bids on several houses and we
learned a lot about the housing market
right now and we made bids over asking
price
and people came in with all cash offers
and we just couldn't afford even some of
the other houses that we wanted
eventually we found a really nice house
it was
three bedroom two bath with a detached
garage that we've turned into a studio
space
and
what we've
learned throughout this process is that
we want to be embedded in a local
community that is caring kind not
overwhelming but there were also some
things that we wanted to avoid that do
take place in a big city so there are a
few things like
emf small electro smog right there's so
many cell towers
there's a website that we went to where
you could check how many cell towers are
near where you live and
my apartment that was in west hollywood
there was like a thousand towers within
a three mile radius and you still can't
get good get good coverage there isn't
that sad yeah it really is and where
where new houses there's one tower
within like a three mile radius wow and
we don't get great coverage there
and also we've decided not to have home
internet not to have a tv at home and so
and i don't keep my phone all around the
house hey it's a paperweight most of the
place is in the house but we have the
entryway rule as well so as soon as we
walk in we just set the phone in this
one area so i'm sort of devoid of
technology in the home and all the sort
of electro smog but also all the
technological distractions the digital
clutter that has infiltrated all of our
lives and so i have to intentionally go
somewhere if i want to work if i need to
be on the internet
or
well the other reason that i wanted to
move to a smaller community is to shop
locally we've been talking about that
during this private episode here
but the importance of shopping locally
versus shopping online it's not that
we're allergic to shopping online but
shopping locally means i get to support
the local community the local people the
local passions local businesses
who tend to be far more passionate about
their product or service than
a major multinational corporation like
walmart or amazon i can default to those
things if if i can't find what i need
locally i'll give you one example right
i went to our local hardware store so i
needed a t10 light bulb which is a very
specific kind of light bulb they didn't
have it at the local hardware store and
i'm like okay can you order it and he
was like actually no it turns out we
can't even order it and so
i looked a few other places couldn't
find it went on to amazon was able to
find it in fact it was helpful because
there were several options that were bad
options with poor reviews but then i
found one with some pretty solid reviews
and made a choice based on that i felt
good about it because
i was shopping intentionally but if i'm
buying food i can go to local butcher a
local grocery store local restaurant if
i'm buying honey there's a local my
local honey dealer i call him
and there's several local bookstores and
there is a local community and also we
want to be closer to nature and so
across the street from where we live
it's not our yard but there's this giant
uh wilderness area that is public open
to the public so many many acres of
trails and access to nature so not
having to own nature but having it
available to us was something that was
really important to us being close to
mountains a lot of mountains there where
we lived and but it's also close enough
to the beach
that within 15-20 minutes we can get to
the beach if we want to and
we still have access to the big city we
can come down to los angeles whenever we
want we're i'm here in los angeles right
now and i can still make it at home
tonight for
dinner so yes we decided to leave los
angeles not because we were running from
los angeles but we had something else to
run toward a place that we wanted to
make what we think is our forever home
the place where we want to live for the
rest of our lives a very simple home
it's not oversized i will say
one room does have a one bedroom has a
walk-in closet
which is like the only downside for me
am i going to do with all this closet
space sounds like a fourth bedroom to me
technically if you could fit a bed in it
it's a bedroom that's right man i'm 40
years old
this is the first time like uh i guess
it started in 2020
that the norm
was to
bid over the asking price on uh buying a
new home
that that's i mean i don't know if
that's like is that the new norm now
like is that gonna be normal forever i
don't know
but yeah the housing market is uh yeah
is insane but
you guys found one you gotta make
congratulations that's awesome yeah
thanks and i i think you're right this
is the new norm for now and in the
future there will be a new norm yeah and
then
yeah maybe that's a nickname for new
sean abnormal sean
[Laughter]
we're still uh we're still trying to
vote on that yeah but yeah we we bid on
two houses before we got this one got
them through the whole process and and
people swooped in and and took those
houses before us but
it's the chinese farmer parable right
because i'm really glad they did because
we found the home that we would like to
spend the rest of our lives in yeah it's
very simple
and yet it's just right for us and our
neighbors i got the biggest selling
point of the house was not the house it
was the neighborhood and the neighbors
in the neighborhood
a lot of houses that are sort of run
down and not in the best shape but the
neighbors are amazing it's a very
blue-collar sort of up-and-coming
neighborhood but we got to meet a lot of
the neighbors and they're some of the
most friendly people that i've ever met
and so i think that is so much more
important than
the average home price in the
neighborhood yeah the question is
who are my neighbors and to whom will i
be a neighbor i think we have to
consider that as well yeah
ways that we knew we were ready to buy a
house is was a my wife's strong desire
for
owning a home planting roots in a
community yes
and a speci specific community right and
i think this is a perfect segue into
what we're going to talk to podcast
shawn about
is
beck's found the community in which she
wants to spend the rest of her life
and i agree with that uh with respect to
the community that we've identified up
there in
and
i've realized that oh like there are
there's some amazing people here but we
considered other places as well i mean
we obviously consider los angeles where
our studio is
in various parts of los angeles because
los angeles is really like 88 different
communities all sort of i remember when
sean first came here he was looking like
up in azusa
and other places it's way out there yeah
in fact you took me down there that's
where i bought
my honda the motorcycle oh that's right
yeah we drove out there together yep um
and so like you were looking at
different places torrance was another
place you were looking
and uh
bex and i have spent the last five years
exploring different neighborhoods when
we do the screenless saturday thing that
danny was doing
last weekend like you just you kind of
start to learn more about the city right
and so one of the ways you know you're
ready mallory is you start to learn a
place and you start to fall in love with
the intangibles we had a question
earlier where someone asked like is it
logical for me to buy a house at this
age or whatever
and the honest answer is like
yeah you might be able to pull out a
sheet of paper get all the pros and cons
and then feel miserable even though all
the pros worked out for me on the paper
it looks great yeah it's great on paper
the difference is this is two
dimensional we live in a 3d world right
yeah well 4d if you could smell ryan
right now
smell is the fourth dimension i smell
great right now i'm taking it in my hair
products smell amazing the pheromones i
find myself gravitating
easy sean we're on camera yeah
save that for later i couldn't agree
more like uh so i talked about how
mariah and i have that condom in
missoula like i
knew it was time to buy a home there
because like i am i feel i feel very
very drawn to missoula i would not buy a
home for the sake of it to airbnb out in
uh dayton ohio or somewhere where i
didn't plan on visiting a lot um but
yeah i think i totally agree with the
sentiment there man like if it's if
you're being pulled towards somewhere
like that is that is one sign that hey
maybe it's time to
put some roots down maybe you want to
drop an anchor in this in that uh
community where you yeah where you
really feel that sense of community
right the belonging that's right and so
and sometimes it takes a while to figure
that out too and so visiting a place
you might feel pulled to several places
and realizing maybe you're pulled there
for a season of life it's not a forever
thing this happened to me in missoula
where i really enjoyed moving to montana
originally when you and i moved to
montana ryan we moved there for four
months cabin side of mountain middle of
nowhere yeah a couple hours away from
missoula yeah we were with queensberg
yeah yeah
we found ourselves we were in between
butte and missoula
we clearly found ourselves gravitating
toward
missoula yes and uh no no there's a
reason it looks like butt
i've heard several of like native
montana
reason it's spelled like how about you
talk about evil knievel's hometown that
way yeah do you know in 1890 that um
butte was the second largest city west
of the mississippi oh wow the san
francisco than butte oh wow and then
it's been a slight decline ever since
well once they once they raped the land
right i mean it might
it looks terrible there too when you go
there like some of that open mining yeah
they've just like tore out yeah
ripped it right out it actually is known
for the most uh
the most toxic hole
it's a super side didn't it i thought
that was your mom i thought it was your
mom
good thing this is a private podcast
it is it's a super sight yeah it is like
it is the most toxic pit in in america
because of all the the mining that went
on and all the pollution that's down in
this lake you see like yeah you jump in
there like and jump out with like three
other arms growing up yeah yeah you
won't have superpowers don't do that
right right exactly we've seen toxic
avenger it doesn't work that way are you
guys saying that it's a it's a a butte
hole
it is a beautiful
hey uh uh sean two cut his mic please
there's uh i have never seen people more
passionate than people of butte they
don't even call it butte montana it's
butte america oh wow because they yeah
you've never heard that i've never heard
that oh yeah like people from bu they
don't call it butte montana they're like
we're from butte america because like
they are so proud
of of their their hometown they got so
they got new pride is this the whole
like the boiling of the frog thing
the funny thing is i've never met a
person from butte that i dislike yeah
yeah 100 yeah that's totally agree and
uh
and so like you know we're we're joking
about butte obviously but like just
because butte is sort of sandwiched
between two of the most desirable places
in montana between missoula and bozeman
i gravitate more toward bozeman i found
out later but also with missoula i
figured out how important weather was to
me
and uh there are other cities that
really stand out to me the ones i
mentioned another one that stands out
we've gone to a lot fargo north dakota
yeah it's a great place that one always
surprises me every time you bring it up
though oh yeah it's oh man winter there
just in summer too which surprised me i
thought oh
it's kind of out there on the plane it
probably won't be that humid mm-hmm no
no it is no no no no no no it feels like
midwest humidity it's yeah it's enjoying
this spring and fall are really amazing
it's like yes that's actually perfect
it's one of the most intense cities in
the united states especially for climate
right every year the weather channel
like votes at the
the worst weather in the country
but i think part of that when you see
these nine foot snow drifts
remember when uh greg did his his ted we
did a tedx talk uh tedx fargo and greg
was doing a talk at this conference we
were speaking at and he showed
this picture of like nine foot snow
drifts covering up stop signs and
everything else but what it did is it
like created this
community of people who almost like were
uniting
in spite of
the weather yeah and so that weather
sort of created this amazing artistic
beautiful community of outstanding
people that i'd never expected we went
to go speak at a conference in fargo i'm
like what the hell is in oh wow this
place is awesome some of the heartiest
people then yeah they're amazing yeah
100 a few other cities that really stand
out to me salt lake city and tucson yeah
you don't like snow but you like salt
lake city right i wouldn't live there in
the winter
salt lake city is probably my favorite
designed city oh god it's uh what was
the um the podcast up you uh introduced
me to about 99 invisible yeah yeah they
talk about how like it's so well plotted
out like every block is 660 feet yeah
and and so the whole you know exactly
where you are from the names of the
street how how close you are relative to
the temple that's in the middle of salt
lake city yeah and like just so many
lanes like it's real wide they made it
so uh back in the day you could turn a
horse and a carriage around with one
user no like you know five-point turns
you could do it in one u-turn didn't
brigham young say so they wouldn't cuss
the drivers oh yeah it would be easy to
do i've never heard that
yeah that makes sense
that's great you know for me and i know
you hate this city josh but uh man
portland was like is definitely up there
on my list and that's why i like
missoula because it was like a it was a
much smaller portland i feel like see i
don't hate portland i hate the weather
there i love the city of portland and
the walkability the food scene there is
amazing
it's just raining all the time and gray
all the time
it's not as great as missoula but like
it's significant yeah dayton's pretty
gray too but if you go north of the what
we call the dmz in ohio you go north of
i-70 it gets even greater it's like
akron for example is a lot like dayton
but just rainier it's rainier than
seattle right yeah or where new sean is
from he's from youngstown and it gets
pretty gray in there yeah yeah you're
gonna see more ways than one
for those of us spending youngstown just
that i want to put my vote in for bend
oregon if you like portland but don't
want the weather
it's the it's central oregon rather than
the pacific northwest that's right and
you get a lot of the same food and
culture
microbreweries but you've got the same
amount of sun as you do here in southern
california oh wow mostly mild winters
unless you want to go up on the mountain
and snowboard band i lived there for
five years ben the uh the location of
the last blockbuster video rental store
oh really yeah they have that on netflix
have you seen that ryan no oh it's great
it's called the last blockbuster there's
a documentary about it what a like
there's something about netflix rubbing
it in blockbuster's face doing a
documentary about the last blockbuster
on on netflix
we were going to do i talked about this
briefly but you might not remember it we
were originally before the whole
pandemic thing it's totally screwed up
everything but
we were going to screen
out less is now
at the last blockbuster store yes in ben
or and then like of course
the whole pandemic yeah it would have
been great just to be able to because
they were doing an airbnb thing there
for a while right where you could rent
it out and sleep there
they only did that for two nights though
and it it cost something like you have
to charge for an airbnb it was just a
marketing thing but it cost like 16
cents
wow to sleep at the block to sleep with
the blockbuster yeah oh wow i used to
really enjoy going to blockbuster dude
there's still some movie rental places
that yeah well that's what we're trying
to
becks and ella and i are trying to
figure out now as we've moved into this
new living environment no internet at
home yeah which means like i can't
connect my sonos speakers um and what do
i do and we started like asking the
question because we don't want ella to
have access to a glowing screen to
listen to music yeah they don't make
ipods anymore yeah and
yeah this is a podcast there's no more
pods but there's still a cast right i
don't think i realize that they they
officially stopped manufacturing they
yeah
they just no kidding
i think there are e-ink uh tablets there
are ink tablets that run android and
that you can use as a full-blown tablet
yeah i just don't i don't want her to
have distractions on the screen i wanted
to have music without the visual side of
it yeah except and so we've we've made
some
queries and so we just wondered out loud
you know what is the do we get a record
player do we get her a cd player yeah
and get a dvd player to watch movies i
guess you don't have a tv so you
wouldn't even yeah be able to do that
right they still have red boxes that
blows my mind i know like that's still a
viable business
yeah and so these are cities i i thought
about tucson is one of my favorite
cities in the country if i if i didn't
live in
tucson would have been one of the places
i really would have liked to live
weather-wise it's nice to set monsoon
season the cost of living there is is
better than most places in the mountain
states
and i found the amazing community there
every time we've gone there we've
interviewed the minimalist architect
frank in our first film and every time
i've gone there i've just fallen in love
with
the essence of the place the intangibles
and so this gets back to
mallory's question
it's like
quite often there's just a feeling
and you can't know what that feeling is
going to be until you really explore
and you might fall out of love with the
city as well missoula i fell in love
with and then over time i decided it was
time to sort of graduate from missoula
said divorce right yeah unfortunately i
ended up divorcing missoula i stayed too
long yeah and so walking away at the
appropriate time is also something that
is
important
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit
patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free